bien es hora de seguir trabajando con
estos problemas del s&p y como ya faltan
muy pocos para acabar esta sección vamos
a darle con todo para ver si los
acabamos en este vídeo am tengo ahora el
problema número 15
nos quedamos resolviendo este problema
el problema número 15 que dice una tasa
de medida o un vaso de precipitados
contienen jugo de naranja en un quinto
de su capacidad
am vamos a hacer esta tasa de medida
imagínense que tengo aquí a esta parte
después se abre algo así por acá tengo
esta tasa y después este baja
y aquí tengo a mi casa oa mi vaso de
precipitados y esto que estoy coloreando
es la parte de abajo es la base de esta
tasa y bueno la primera quinta parte es
decir esta primera quinta parte y es más
déjenme ponerlo con una línea esta
primera quinta parte va a estar llena de
jugo de naranja así que nosotros venimos
y le hacíamos jugo de naranja a esta
parte muy bien ahora la primera quinta
parte están llena de jugo de naranja es
decir un quinto de esta tasa o es de
este vaso de precipitados está lleno de
jugo de naranja
de naranja porque después vamos a meter
más cubos después dice lo que sobra si
después se llena todo lo que resta de la
tasa de medición con una mezcla de jugos
de naranja uva y piña y cada uno de
ellos en la misma cantidad que fracción
de la cantidad finales de jugo de
naranja
fíjate bien aquí sobran cuatro quintos
si en esta parte tengo el primer quinto
de este vaso de precipitados entonces lo
que resta aquí son cuatro quintos y de
estos cuatro quintos vamos a llenar por
completo esta taza y para llenar por
completo esta taza déjame hacer una
línea por acá
imagínate que este es el borde de la
taza de lo que sobra lo voy a dividir en
tres lo voy a dividir en esta parte de
aquí lo voy a dividir en esta parte de
aquí de tal manera que la primera parte
la voy a llenar de jugo de piña entonces
la primera parte la voy a llenar de jugo
de piña la segunda parte la voy a llenar
de jugos de uva así que le voy a poner
el jugo de uva
la última parte de la voy a llenar con
más jugo de naranja aquí le voy a poner
más jugo de naranja perfecto ahora sí
creo que se entiende un poco más este
problema yo lo que tengo es un vaso de
precipitados del cual de la primera
quinta parte la vamos a llenar de jugo
de naranja y las otras cuatro quintas
partes lo voy a dividir entre tres y de
estas cuatro quintas partes uno de los
tercios de estas cuatro quintas partes
también lo vamos a llenar de jugo de
naranja lo que me preguntan es cuánto
jugo de naranja en total tengo en este
vaso de precipitados bueno primeramente
tengo este un quinto y después de estos
cuatro quintos de aquí no voy a tomar un
tercio de estos cuatro quintos para
llenarlo también con jugo de naranja por
lo tanto me voy a tomar estos cuatro
quintos y a estos cuatro quintos los voy
a multiplicar por un tercio es decir voy
a dividir estos cuatro quintos entre
tres y de estos tres partes una de estas
tres partes va a ser de jugo de naranja
por lo tanto una de estas tres partes de
los cuatro quintos va a tener también
jugo de naranja y cuánto es esto bueno
pues hay que multiplicar esto
y está por este 4 por una es 4 y después
5 por 3 es 15 15 perfecto ahora esta es
la cantidad de jugo de naranja que tengo
aquí en los cuatro quintos esto también
es de jugo de naranja jugo de naranja
pero si yo quiero saber en total cuánto
jugo de naranja tengo pues bueno a estos
4 15 a vos a estos 4 15 a vos le tengo
que sumar este un quinto que
inicialmente le pusimos a este vaso de
precipitados y cuando esto bueno pues
hay que sacar el mínimo común múltiplo
el mínimo común múltiplo de 5 y 15 es 15
quien se acabe una vez en 15 por 4 es 4
más 5 cabe tres veces en 15 5 por 3 15 3
por 1 es tres más tres y esto es igual a
7 15 a vos y esa es mi respuesta mi
respuesta son 7 15 años del vaso van a
estar llenos de jugo de naranja es un
poco menos de la mitad de este vaso
siento que me hizo vida actitud yo un
poco al responder esta parte de la
pregunta
es que ya marcó medio extraño este libro
pero bueno vamos a hacer mejor el
siguiente problema el problema número el
problema número 16 así que déjenme
borrar la pantalla y ahora si trabajemos
con el problema número 16 que dice lo
siguiente si a más 2 b
a más 2b esto es exactamente lo mismo
que el 125 por ciento de 4 vemos que 125
por ciento de 420 bueno el 125 por
ciento 125 por ciento recuerda que esto
lo podemos expresar en su forma decimal
como 1.25 esto es lo mismo que 1.25 por
lo tanto a más 2 b es igual al 125 por
ciento es decir al 1.25 ya viéndolo en
su forma decimal de 4 b de 4 b de 4 b y
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale a
entre b exacto realmente lo que quiero
es despejar de aquí el valor de entre b
así que vamos a trabajarlo
primero voy a agarrar esta ecuación y
vamos a ver qué sale de aquí a más dos
ven esto es igual y cuánto es 1.25 por 4
pues vamos a hacerlo 1.25 por 4
esto me da 4 por 520 llevamos 24 por 28
y 210 y llevamos 14 por 14 y 15 a
recorrer dos veces el punto estos 55
veces ver y si ahora restó 2 b de ambos
lados de esta igualdad me va a quedar
que am es igual a 3 b pero yo lo que
quiero saber es a / b por lo tanto qué
te parece si divido todo entre b voy a
dividir esta parte entre bien esta parte
entre ven de tal manera que aquí ya
tengo a / b y me va a quedar que entre
vemos el valor de a entre b que es lo
que yo quiero es igual este y este se va
entonces me queda solamente 3 entre b
vale 3 perfecto lo más importante este
problema fue pueden expresar 125 por
ciento como 1.25
así que vamos a resolver el siguiente
problema déjame borrar la pantalla y
vamos a trabajar con el problema 17 que
es el penúltimo problema de esta sección
el problema número 17 que dice lo
siguiente bien y este problema tiene una
recta numérica así que déjenme dibujar
de esta recta numérica y voy a tomar la
recta una recta como por aquí una recta
grande muy bien aquí tengo que para
cavar esta recta numérica por cierto
aquí aquí tengo al cero por acá por acá
tengo al 1
muy bien y después hay cuantos pedazos
hay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 hay ocho divisiones
de aquí de hecho el problema me dice en
la recta numérica siguiente hay nueve
intervalos iguales entre el 0 y el 1
cuál es el valor de x
déjame ponerte aquí con kallman los
intervalos así que déjenme cambiar de
color
son ocho divisiones que tengo que hacer
de aquí a acá así que empecemos a una 2
7 y 8
un intervalo dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve perfecto ya tengo aquí
mis nueve intervalos y x está por aquí a
ver déjame ver con calma es 1 2 3 123
aquí esta raíz de equis de hecho no está
x está aquí ra es de equis y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale x y lo que
quiero saber es el valor de x ahora bien
cada uno de estos intervalos puede tener
un nombre si estoy dividiendo del 0 al 1
en nueve partes cada punto de éstos es
un noveno es decir aquí tengo un noveno
aquí tengo dos novenos aquí tengo a tres
novenos aquí tengo cuatro novenos aquí
tengo cinco novenos aquí tengo seis
novenos aquí tengo siete novenos aquí
tengo ocho novenos y bueno para
corroborar ocho novenos
uno es
9 90% 9 novenos es lo mismo que uno así
que vamos bien a cada uno de estos
puntos es un noveno dos novenos tres lo
menos así sucesivamente y por lo tanto
raíz de equis que hay justo en el punto
de seis novenos o dicho otra manera y ya
podemos expresar la ecuación la ecuación
me quedaría de la siguiente forma raíz
de x es igual la raíz de x vale aquí
está
vale 6 no menos 6 novenos que por cierto
seis novenos tiene tercera arriba y
tercera abajo si seis lo divido entre
tres me queda dos y nueve lo divido
entre tres me queda 3 es decir que seis
novenos es lo mismo que dos tercios de
ellos de x es igual a dos tercios o
dicho de otra manera si elevó al
cuadrado ambas partes de esta igualdad
me va a quedar que x es igual a dos
tercios elevado al cuadrado y bueno dos
tercios elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 4
por lo tanto ya tengo mi respuesta x es
igual a 41 menos x es igual a 4 novenos
y esa es la solución de este problema
número 17 así que vamos a hacer el
problema número 18 que es el último
problema número 18 18 y me dice en el
plano cartesiano x james la distancia
entre el punto b en el punto b tiene
como coordenadas 10 18 10,18 y el punto
am el punto am tiene como coordenadas x
3 x 3 muy bien es 17 la distancia entre
a ibm es 17 perfecto cuál es uno de los
posibles valores para x y bueno es que
aquí nos va a salir una ecuación
cuadrática
como podemos ver esto bueno yo sé que la
distancia y lo voy a poner aquí esto es
muy importante la distancia al cuadrado
sale de un teorema de pitágoras la
distancia al cuadrado
es esencialmente el cambio x elevado al
cuadrado más el cambio en el cambio y
james elevado al cuadrado creo que es
necesario graficar estos puntos en un
plano cartesiano me tardaría mucho en
ver los posibles resultados igual el
final lo hago
pero por cierto no quiero que se me
olvide también hay otros libros donde te
ponen que la distancia es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de quien de x 2 - x 1 al
cuadrado más 10 2 menos
al cuadrado esto por cierto se ve
bastante en algunos libros de texto
cuando hablan de álgebra lineal pero
bueno creo que mis vídeos lo he
trabajado de esta manera porque se me
hace más intuitiva es decir me estoy
pensando en un teorema de pitágoras sin
embargo estas dos expresiones son
exactamente equivalentes fíjate bien la
distancia al cuadrado aquí pase el
cuadrado del otro lado como raíz
cuadrada es igual al cambio en x es
decir x 2 - x 1 el cambio en x elevado
al cuadrado más el cambio en jeff aquí
está el cambio de dos menos uno elevado
al cuadrado y bueno a mí me gusta
utilizar más esta fórmula de color
salmón así que vamos a ver que me queda
de aquí la distancia elevada al cuadrado
es decir 17 elevado al cuadrado esto es
exactamente igual al cambio en x el
cambio en x elevado al cuadrado así que
me voy a tomar am x menos 16 y voy a
tomar x menos 10 elevado al cuadrado es
decir la diferencia entre los dos
valores de x
esto le tengo que sumar la diferencia
entre los dos valores de james la
diferencia entre los dos valores de qué
es
3 - 18 esto elevado al cuadrado y de
aquí lo que tengo que hacer es obtener
el valor de x
pero como vamos en tiempo changos el
tiempo se me ha pasado muy rápido lo que
voy a hacer en el siguiente vídeo es
terminar este último problema de la
sección 4 del examen 3 del libro la guía
de estudios oficiales del s
así que no te pierdas el siguiente vídeo
donde voy a ver la solución de este
último problema nos vemos en el
siguiente